hello and welcome to the spectator
out loud
each week we ask a handful of writers to
read their pieces from the magazine
aloud this week we have lloyd evans
arguing that the state should stop
subsidizing the national theatre
and start funding britain's bingo halls
then we have lionel shriver on the
difficulties of taking back control
and finally will heaven on the
dissolution of the downside monastery
first up lloyd evans for nearly six
months
our subsidised playhouses notably the
national theatre
have been dark what have we missed
not much some would say nothing at all
and this has come as a surprise to those
of us who are led to believe
that the subsidized theater is critical
to the national conversation
it turns out that the nation can happily
debate political and social issues
without the help of playwrights or
actors
perhaps it's time to re-examine our
state-funded theaters
and the reasons we support them the
national theatre was set up in 1963
soon after the establishment of the
royal shakespeare company in 1961
and both received funding from the arts
council which was founded
in 1946 the leaders of these august
bodies
had a particular reverence for drama
opera
ballet and orchestral music and they
assumed perhaps a little arrogantly
that their preferences were a force for
good and that culture could improve
humanity that theory is still active
today
the website of the beleaguered old vic
proclaims that every time a theater
closes
we lose a chance to make the world
better
but is there any evidence for this
commonly held belief
what role did the theater play in the
development of the bicycle
or the polio vaccine or the internet
which
theater makers contributed to the d-day
landings
the fall of the berlin wall or the good
friday agreement
you could say these examples are
irrelevant because actors and dramatists
don't fight wars or invent things the
theater is a public platform
where ideas can be exchanged and at its
best
it offers a particularly valuable type
of discursive drama
the state of the nation play the
national theater
specializes in this genre stuff happens
by david hare in 2004
examine the iraq war england people very
nice in 2009 by richard beam
chronicled race relations in britain and
this house
in 2012 by james graham looked at the
labour administration in the 1970s
what these plays lacked of course was
any sense of urgency or topicality
and that's inevitable the national
theatre commissions a new script
about a year in advance of the first
night so a political play is bound to
feel dated
by the time it reaches the stage in 2018
david hare's drama i'm not running
looked at a fictional leadership contest
between two center-right labour
politicians
but it completely ignored the ascendancy
of jeremy corbyn
and his hard-left allies so the play
seemed detached from reality
and it undermined the idea that a state
of the nation drama
helps us to understand ourselves the
best political shows
at the national offer nothing more than
a nostalgic backward glance
at recent history the rest of its output
is a mishmash of
high-minded amusements for older and
more affluent audiences in london
and the country at large pays for these
frolics through taxation
so it's very convenient for the national
that so many people still accept
that drama is a civilizing force
but negative consequences flow from this
theory the arts council
seems to believe that black and ethnic
minorities need exposure to the white
theatrical tradition
it readily funds productions of plays by
white authors
performed by non-white actors death of a
salesman by arthur miller
was produced at the young vic in 2019
with an exclusively black cast
and yet the arts council makes no
reciprocal attempt to get white people
into minority cultural genres there's no
funding for white school kids to perform
rap or jazz
you won't find all white reggae bands
receiving public money
where are the grants for white only
drama groups to perform scenes
from the bhagavad gita or the arabian
nights
the traffic all moves in one direction
white drama
often rather tedious stuff is performed
by black or brown people
this quietly affirms the primacy of
white culture and assigns a lower rank
to other artistic traditions
perhaps in the light of the lockdown we
should admit a few home
truths first the national conversation
is not an exclusive property of the
theatre secondly
the dramatic arts are unlikely to make
the world a better place
finally the national theatre is not an
essential public service
it's a luxury and its 18 million pound
annual grant
should be diverted towards cultural
pursuits that genuinely help the
community
and whose advantages are measurable
numerous
creative professions might receive state
aid children's entertainers
stand-up comedians bell ringers skiffle
bands
reading groups bridge clubs beekeeping
fraternities
poetry circles and debating societies i
would argue for three particular
activities
barge ownership gardening and bingo
the east london canal network near my
home is full of exquisitely decorated
narrowboats and barges
the finest of these are certainly works
of art
barges offer social as well as aesthetic
benefits a barge
is a low-cost energy-efficient home
barges support businesses like floating
bookshops or water-borne cafes
mooring fees help to maintain a national
system of waterways which team with
wildlife
youngsters who live on barges acquire
skills in navigation mechanics
and boat maintenance and they learn to
tolerate their barge mates living habits
and to embrace the virtues
of acceptance and forgiveness gardening
certainly deserves to be recognized as
an official part of our culture the word
culture means growth
a gardener like any visual artist must
develop a sense of beauty harmony and
color
he becomes an expert in the science of
botany and he can pass this knowledge
on to others he learns the spiritual
benefits of exercise hard work
and deferred gratification and when his
garden blooms it gives visitors a sense
of calmness and mental wellbeing
finally bingo at first sight a game of
bingo seems a long way from the
activities currently favored by the arts
council
but the connection is very close bingo
is a live theatrical event with a
surprise ending
which rewards the spectators emotionally
it does the same job as hamlet or
oedipus
hamlet is a dramatic quest to identify
the king's murderer
and to placate the gods of vengeance by
punishing the offender
oedipus is a dramatic quest to discover
why the gods are angry with the city
of thebes bingo is a dramatic quest
to find a secret link between a member
of the crowd and the goddess of fortune
that's why people love bingo it has the
satisfying story arc of a courtroom
drama or a detective mystery
it starts with a puzzle and moves
through a process of inquiry
towards an answer that provides delight
and relief it has other benefits
bingo is a social event which
strengthens the ties of communities and
families
it helps the economy as well each player
contributes a small fee
which would not otherwise have been
spent the total sum is handed over to a
prize winner who is likely to splash out
on luxuries and gifts
which boost local businesses and the
government collects its share
in sales taxes as well by coincidence
all three of these activities could be
accommodated on the banks of the thames
where the national theatre now stands
a boat yard might be constructed for
barges to be assembled
and repaired the terrace roofs of the
national would be ideal for public
gardens
and the olivier could become a bingo
hall
that was lloyd evans next
lionel shriver i sympathized with leave
voters who yearned
to take back control of british borders
after all if being a country means
anything
it surely entails first and foremost a
clear understanding of
who comes under that country's
protection and who doesn't
otherwise a country is just a patch on
the map
yet i've always found levers high hopes
for reduced immigration
heartbreaking cutting ties with the eu
was never going to limit migrants out to
put the greatest pressure on british
borders this century
immigrants from outside the eu
especially from
high birth rate countries in africa and
the middle east
who absent and unlikely new agreement by
the end of the brexit transition period
will only be more difficult to return to
the continent
back in 1984 the editorial board of
america's
right-leaning wall street journal argued
for a five-word
constitutional amendment there shall be
open borders but such
outright support for goodie bags
brimming with bottled water and
welcome to the usa coffee mugs on the
american side of the rio grande
is rare two years ago
even the journal backtracked on open
borders
when the board couldn't stick the
reality of what they'd been inviting
a rowdy caravan of more than 7 000
overwhelmingly unskilled
impoverished hondurans teaming towards
texas
the left will often gesture limply
towards controlled immigration
while advocating policies that so reward
violating immigration statutes
and that so tie the hands of immigration
authorities
that the position amounts to open
borders in all but name
these days leftists perceive any
enforcement of immigration law
as racist alas among conservatives
we often see a parallel disingenuousness
center-right politicians make rhetorical
noises about
sending illegal immigrants packing while
never addressing the primary pull
factors
frustrated by bureaucratic impotence
civil servant incompetence endless legal
gambits and appeals
they conspicuously fail to put
deportations
where their mouths are behold
open borders in all but name
during this year's mini deluge of some
5500
unauthorized migrants crossing the
english channel in small boats
though i foretell you ain't seen nothing
yet
the home secretary pretty patel has
clearly been making an effort
but to whittle effect since january last
year
the uk has sent all of 155 boat people
back to europe
so we can share the poor woman's
exasperation
that when 23 illegal migrants were all
set
to be flown back to spain last week the
home office was hit by what
in cyberspace is called a denial of
service attack
a maelstrom of last-minute legal actions
by said patel lefty labor-supporting
lawyers
all 23 amateur seafarers remain in
sconced in britain
without having collected any air miles
once migrants land in kent whose
facilities for migrant children are full
bursting and whose funds for such
services are dry
new arrivals are in like flynn and they
know it
in smartphone world our tourists for
life
are better informed about immigration
law and about what to expect
or even demand on arrival than their own
taxpayer financed lawyers
the odd poor student is brought up to
speed pronto
by a phalanx of ngo worthies whose
driving purpose
is to thwart unfriendly immigration
policies
and who coach refugees on what to say
that's why patel wants to introduce a
new rule to prevent asylum applicants
from adding
different grounds for refugee status
later in the process
chartered deportation flights cost a
mint
last year twelve thousand pounds per
deportee
and you thought ba was steep
that figure excludes the vast resources
required to fight endless court battles
two or three years ago during a protest
intended to block the return of a woman
from zimbabwe
i noted that she'd been turned down for
asylum in britain
seven times yep
there she was on the news still in
london
those seven denials don't merely imply
bother
they imply money
each case can take years as well
allowing migrants to have children or
marry and then
claim a right to family life further
we've established a feedback loop every
time
an ambitious cross-channel kayaker
secures
free housing and health care a little
allowance
and a job on the black market all
without getting wet
our successful adventurer effectively
sends wish you were here postcards to
multiple friends and relatives every
additional relative
means still more relatives get
permission to stay
because they have a relative in the uk
brought in by allied nations justifiably
guilt-ridden about not having taken in
enough
jews fleeing the nazis the post-war
asylum system is now
widely abused only in the past few years
have i even heard the expression
illegal immigrant in the uk before then
every uninvited visitor was an asylum
seeker
however well migrants have read up on
the convincing reasons to claim asylum
the chances that a majority of europe's
purported asylum seekers are
actually escaping persecution are slight
said widespread abuse reduces the
chances that
genuinely persecuted applicants are
given the green light
but little matter most failed applicants
aren't going anywhere
western immigration enforcement is
drowning in due process
it's too costly too complicated and too
hard
in some it's a farce the deck is
powerfully stacked against the state
because the state has stacked the deck
against itself
highly complex systems are easy to game
and that's assuming illegal arrivals
even bother to game them
word to the wise never trust
immigration figures those are only the
people the government
knows about
good luck to ms patel with overhauling
asylum law in her
fair borders bill slated for later this
year
but i hope she forgives my cynicism
the home office's history on immigration
is chaotic
and ineffectual as well as arbitrary
for the department has sometimes chosen
to put its foot down with the most
deserving
c windrush
one bit of advice pretty offshore
asylum applications if you can because
the moment
migrants physically set foot in your
country
they're your problem
still i'm not holding my breath for
britain taking back control of its
borders
anytime soon that was lionel shriver
and finally will heaven
the monks of downside abbey and somerset
elected a new albert last thursday
according to 6th century rules laid down
by saint
the next day they sent an email
notification
saying they had voted to make a new
start and to seek a new place to live
it was a shock to those who know the
place the monks will leave behind a
beautiful abbey church
built in the gothic revival style it's
166 foot tower visible for miles around
a monastery in cloisters the largest
monastic library in britain
and a grand looking public school with
more than 300 pupils
it's as if a piece of english
catholicism like a decaying chunk of
church masonry
has fallen away but it has been a long
time
coming so many of the monks i knew while
at school at downside
in the early 2000s some of them towering
figures that seemed at the time
have died or left already some with
their reputations intact
others with their lives in ruins
one is now a priest and a thriving
american parish
another is in rome a former abbot
quit entirely and got married to one of
the school nurses
for the handful of mostly elderly monks
left the decision to leave
cannot have been easy they will have
prayed
from dawn till dusk they know
that there were enormous failings which
allowed child abuse to take place in the
school
for decades the guilty men
as in other catholic settings were then
wrongly protected
by the institution an unwavering
deference
from lay catholics towards them helped
but it was a bond of loyalty between the
monks themselves that led to disaster
these bonds were almost always prized
over the safety
of the boys in their care
by definition monks aren't worldly
but their political naivety and
stubbornness in the past few years
back fired badly about eight years ago
when historic abuse at downside was
unearthed
there were calls including from me for
the school
and monastery to separate formally
they weren't by a single charitable
trust and all the trustees were monks
who held the purse strings
and therefore called the shots even
after a lay head master was appointed
i argued my case for separation on a
visit to the school
and was told by a monk that they would
resist such a conversation
this was surely a mistake had they
managed the overdue
reforming of the school's governance
with a little more foresight and
humility
long before several of them appeared in
the dock at theresa may's independence
inquiry into child sexual abuse
things might have been different
nevertheless the monk's decision to
leave is a bold move
and the right one now guided by an
outsider
the new albert brought in from belmont
abbey
they've put lay catholics in charge of
the school and finally set it free
at great financial cost during the
splitting of the single trust into
separate school and monastery trusts
renaissance paintings were dusted off
and sold at sotheby's
including a bernardo's gnarly depiction
of saint john the baptist
that went for 225 000 pounds
it may not work in the long term so
mary's shaftsbury
a west country catholic girls school
where a few of my friends
wives went there's recently shut down
after too many loss making years in a
row
but it is well worth trying downside
for its faults remains hugely popular
with current parents
their sons and daughters and former
pupils who visit
especially at easter and for wonderful
midnight masses at christmas
one american alumnus recently gave a
million dollars for bursaries
that's pocket money to a school like
eaton but a significant sign here of
faith
in the future
the monks will also see this move in a
wider context and whether it for that
reason
they're really a migrant community
founded in exile in daoi
flanders in 1606 where they trained
priests
for the english mission two of whom were
martyred and made scenes
as an english monastic house with a
small college
they were forced to flee back to england
after the french revolution
finding lodgings with a former pupil in
shropshire until they bought a farmhouse
at downside
in 1814
to begin with the chapel they built
there was a disguise to the outside
world
with no distinguishing features the sums
that locals were wary of these strange
newcomers in their black habits
but in the decades after catholic
emancipation
the monks began to assert themselves
building the abbey
described by pesner as the most splendid
demonstration
of the renaissance of roman catholicism
in england
and buying hundreds of acres more land
the school began to prosper
and resemble its non-catholic rivals
such as shervin and winchester
there is no question that especially in
the second half of the 20th century
there was what one former monk called
the heart of darkness a downside
despite its outward signs of success and
the positive experience
of so many pupils like me
it has been a painful decade especially
for the victims of abuse
and i would add those monks who are good
men
trying to live their vocations
faithfully
but it feels as if the light is finally
breaking through that was will heaven
thank you for listening to this week's
edition of spectator out loud
and if you enjoyed this why not consider
watching spectator tv
each week andrew neal hosts the week in
60 minutes
alongside an assortment of spectator
writers and guests
you can tune in next week on thursday at
six o'clock
go to www.tv.spectator.co.uk
we hope to see you there
you